what's a caucus it's a party for
political parties an important part of
how Democrats and Republicans choose
their presidential candidates most
states vote for their presidential
candidates in primaries which work just
like a general election you can vote
morning noon or night with a secret
ballot but in some states you have to
vote for your party's candidate at these
live events called caucuses the rules
vary a little from state to state but
here's how they work you go to a school
or a civic center where representatives
for each candidate try to sway undecided
voters after these speeches caucus goers
choose their favorite candidate
sometimes with a handwritten ballot this
whole process can take hours problem is
most voters don't have all that extra
time and energy to vote that's one
reason voter turnout is lower in states
with caucuses than in states with
primaries so I do them well it's an
American tradition in 1624 the leader of
the Virginia Colony adapted caucus from
the algonquin word for council it was a
call-in ass way of talking politics
without the British interfering the
rules have changed a lot since then but
caucuses are still an important sign of
how the party faithful are voting and
the presidential candidates who win the
first caucuses in Iowa instantly gain
frontrunner status and all the perks
that come with it but the winner of Iowa
shouldn't get too excited after all
there are 49 other states left up for
grabs
you